hi my name is Jan fat Weiss I'm from
Virginia Commonwealth University in the
department's of microbiology and
immunology and obstetrics and
gynaecology and today I'm going to talk
about multi Olmec approaches for the
study of vaginal renewal communities so
as many of you know there are microbes
living all over our bodies tiny
microorganisms that live in ecosystems
and form communities however until
relatively recently we knew very little
about how these organisms collaborate in
communities and impact our health so the
different ecosystems of the body the
oral the skin the gastrointestinal the
uro general regions all have very
different landscapes and up until
recently we were focused very much on
the bad organisms the pathogens that
potentially could cause disease however
relatively recently new technologies
have made it possible to study these
organisms in their communities without
without cultivating them and that's it's
really changed the paradigms for how we
can think about the study of the
microbes or the human microbiome so I
became involved in this work as part of
the human microbiome project that began
back in 2007 there were two phases of
this project the first phase of the
project was thought it was the human
microbiome project phase one and that
was really one of the first large-scale
efforts to look at who are the
microorganisms that live in our bodies
what are the what are they who is there
and I was also involved in a study that
was part of the the latest phase of the
human microbiome project that is known
as both the NIH her final project for
sometimes people might days to age and
in that phase in past the the surveys of
who is actually there and looking at how
do these microbial communities interact
with each other and with the human host
over time and in that study we're moving
past just just markers of
organisms are there into what we call
multi-omics science and so that includes
a lot of different omics technologies
some of these you may have heard before
so 16s surveys and I'll go into that
just a bit of depth in a moment gives us
a way to survey what organisms are
present in the community meta genomics
is all of the genes of all of the
organisms so if we take a swab sample I
studied the vaginal microbiome so if we
take a swab sample and we extract the
DNA you have human DNA there we have
viral DNA we have DNA from yeast we have
DNA from bacteria and if we sequence
that we can look at all of the genes
from all of the organisms and as you can
imagine there are lots of different
kinds of things that can be done with
that sorts of data and then we can go to
meta transcriptome mix so as you
remember from molecular biology and DNA
those mix RNA and that's really what's
functional so in this case rather than
just what is present or what is the
predicted function of these communities
we can actually look at what these
communities are doing at a given time
and further if we go through we can look
at the meta proteome or all of the
proteins from a particular sample so
that could be human proteins bacterial
proteins viral proteins all of these in
a sample to try to understand things at
that level and then further the
metabolites so what are these organisms
producing what are the host cells
producing and then integrate all of
these all mixed together to really try
to get a fuller picture of what's
happening between the microbial
communities and their human host
recently the work from the HMP to
project which is also known as the
integrative human microbiome project was
published in a series of manuscripts
that were in nature nature medicine and
other nature family journals I was part
of the group from Virginia Commonwealth
University that focused on the pregnancy
and preterm birth there were two other
groups one was focused on inflammatory
bowel disease and the other off
pre-diabetes and so you might think well
these conditions seem to not have much
in common with the exception that
they're all conditions that your host
microbiome interactions are quite
important but
really brought these projects together
when the types of data and the types of
analyses that were common across all of
these looking at host microbiome
interactions with the longitudinal
component so looking at how that is
impacted over time so all of these
resources are now available I've
included links later in the presentation
and so if any of you were involved in
method development or have other
interest to reuse this data these were
generated as a community resource and
they're now available to the community
so again as the project director for the
project at VCU which we called the multi
omec microbiome study pregnancy
initiative or moms p i-- we enrolled a
cohort in in virginia also collaborated
with a group at the Global Alliance to
prevent prematurity and silver in
Washington State and we also
collaborated with a group at the Medical
College of South Carolina our initial
analyses focused on a cohort of women
specifically a group of 45 women you
know delivered spontaneous and preterm
and matched controls so I will I won't
focus too much on the results of that
from this paper because I'd like to go
through and use this as an opportunity
to really talk about the methods and
what's possible for you to do no matter
what your system is but I will go
through and just introduce that so that
as I go through and talk about that
throughout you'll have a sense of what
why we were doing this part of the study
the idea that the forest or the rain the
forest being a good analogy for what is
optimal health or the gut and the ideas
different species come together they all
provide different functions and all of
those functions are important to health
and the paradigm for the vaginal
environment is really quite a bit
different although there are different
ways to be healthy and we see
differences across different populations
I would say the classic paradigm is that
typically one species often one of lack
vassilis turns to dominate and keep
other organisms other anaerobic
organisms out of the environment and one
of the things I think that's really
important when we think about using this
as a model system is that the system is
a bit more simple and so when we start
looking at how do we go through and try
to look at multi Olmec methods and how
do we go through and really understand
that the system is really one that I
think is quite ideal for doing this so
just as the paradigms of optimal health
are different between the guts and the
human vagina so are the paradigms of
imbalance so in the gut we often think
what functionality has been wiped out
and how to restore that in the vaginal
environment it's often a matter of what
are the less favorable species that are
present that may impact risk for things
such as pregnancy complications
including preterm birth we're certainly
interested in mechanisms of ascending
infection up into the upper female
reproductive tract and also for
acquisition of sexually transmitted
diseases including HIV and so it's
become appreciated with the vaginal
microbiome that there is a role both in
preterm birth in HIV acquisition and I
think that's quite important for
understanding some of the health
disparities that exist globally for both
of these conditions so please stay here
these are just um the global rates of
preterm birth and the global incidence
of HIV and you can see here that there
they're really quite there are
differences that exist globally and
there are some similarities there and
one of the things that my group is
really interested in exploring is
whether the vaginal microbiome may
actually play a positive role in some of
these similarities in terms of global
health disparities most of my work has
been focused on pregnancy and preterm
birth these were published in the nature
in nature medicine publications that I
refer to a bit earlier and I will refer
to some of those throughout so before I
kind of get into the weeds and talk
about some of the specifics on the multi
omec microbiome methods I want to just
take kind of it
the 10,000 foot view and think about
what are the challenges as we're moving
forward and I think that's something
that's quite important because at the
end of this place where we've really
gone through and we're looking at how
multi-omics science has evolved
relatively rapidly there are challenges
that the discovery front about how do we
push the methods the technologies the
approaches that we can use to really ask
eight things that we've never asked
before and then some of the technologies
that are becoming a bit mature there are
different types of challenges that are
really important for how do we
understand the bias how do we make sure
that studies are reproducible how do we
go through and make sure that we can
harmonize against them across studies
that are that are done across different
populations as we move towards
evidence-based medicine so I mentioned
this this paradigm before the human
microbiome project if there was really a
more from who is there surveying
communities to understanding what
they're doing and how they're
interacting with their hosts over time
and I think we can think about that
through some of the omics technologies
as well so I'll start with the 16s rRNA
surveys which is one of the most
commonly used methods in microbiome
science to assay communities it's not
the only one that it's perhaps the most
common and then we'll go through some of
the other omics assays which are really
starting to push the frontiers
I think the 16s ribosomal surveys are a
really good example of one where a lot
of really good methods already exist but
there's still opportunities but I think
those opportunities are ones we're
really looking to go through a push the
forefront of reproducibility and
starting to think about how we can go
through and make sure in these cases are
you have proper control set up we
understand bias and the studies are
going to be to be reproducible so you
might ask why are we using the 16s gene
to classify a communities and in some
ways the classification based on
morphology might work pretty well for
macro organisms but for micro organisms
it doesn't work so well and so rather
than using that we can use a gene the
16s ribosomal gene which is part of the
protein making apparatus and has been
conserved in
bacteria as a marker gene one where we
can go through and say okay who's there
can we go through and just use this one
game as a marker for the evolutionary
lineage to try to understand what
bacteria are there and then and then
classify those and so the approach here
is to design Universal primers that are
to the conserved region of this gene and
to amplify those regions and that would
amplify from a DNA sample that we know
we take just a vaginal swab sample in my
face and then extract everything of
human DNA bacterial DNA all sorts of
bacterial DNA and then you amplify and
it would only amplify but the bacterial
DNA for this particular gene and then
use the variable regions to try to
understand and classify what that looks
like and there's so now there's some
very good approaches for doing that sort
of classification and I'll talk about
some of the more exciting methods that I
think of and more recently become
available so the basic idea is you start
with this gene you go through and
amplify based on the conserved regions
and then you sequence the variable
regions and then use some sort of
classification method the standard
approaches have either been mapping to a
reference database where you have a
reference dependent sort of approach
which I think have particularly are
particularly useful as we start thinking
about clinical Diagnostics or some of
the approaches that were that were used
where we go through and actually just
think de novo from scratch how do we
compare all of the sequences to each
other figure out how many things we have
and then and then classify it the number
of things will after we've done that
sorting and then from there however we
do the classification we can go
downstream and start to think about what
sort of analyses and so in this case you
know maybe there are two different
groups or you have a case in a control
and you want to ask are there
differences and what are those
differences and so well this is a
relatively mature technology there are
still quite a few challenges as we start
to think about how do we move this
towards translation one of those is in
terms of classification a couple of
years ago Ben Callahan and Susan Holmes
published a method using exact sequence
variants rather than
additional taxonomic units now I know
for those of you who aren't idea here
one of the things that was really
interesting is that they used the
Equality information from the sequences
rather than just the sequences that came
off of the machine to be able to
actually understand how can we go
through and actually understand what are
the exact sequences rather than just
kind of rough rough units and this is
something that chirps for those of you
who are doing it I would encourage you
if your using a de novo based approach
to to to look at these methods of one
example of why that this sort of method
was important if the same group followed
up on this and showed that they were
able to find this sort of a massive
method allowed for an association of
gardnerella vaginalis which is a vaginal
organism to be in their study was
associated with preterm birth but it
wasn't for all gardnerella it was only
for ones that had this particular
variant and so this sort of analysis
allows that level of resolution and i
think is quite exciting another another
area that I think is very very exciting
is looking at what sort of controls are
needed both positive controls and
negative controls there's quite a big
push in the community right now to
encourage journals and authors to
publish controls in addition to the
samples one example that there's been
quite a controversy in the field over
the papers that have come out of the
placental microbiome there was a recent
a recent paper that just came out in
nature that suggests and this is one of
the one of several recent papers that
using negative controls the recent
studies show a lack of support for a
placental microbiome so I think that's
something that's really important in
terms of experimental design and in
terms of transparency and reporting is
to make sure that controls are part of
these sorts of experiments there are a
number of methods that are continuing to
go on to look at how what sorts of
things can impact bias here's one
looking at the GC content and there
others as well
others in terms of wiring that where the
statistical challenges with working with
these kinds of data so if you think
about this really if you take if you use
this approach
4:16 I see cleansing everything they're
looking at is pretty much proportional
it's not necessarily doesn't tell you
exactly how much bacteria is there it
tells you relatively how much bacteria
is there which means there's the D this
constrained in some ways and that leads
to some some challenges and yeah the
other part of that is that there it's
sparse and that's just a fancy way of
saying that there are lots of zeroes so
there are lots of people who don't have
a particularly organism where one
particular sample has that and so those
sorts of qualities of data present some
unique challenges and there's still
quite a bit of exciting work going on in
terms of whether the best statistical
approaches to handle this type of data
and the other thing that's quite
interesting is is using technology to
push this forward so most of the studies
that use 16s sequencing for microbiome
surveys use just some of the variable
region using short read sequencing but
there have been some very exciting
approaches using 16s using long reads
such as the using pat bio sequencing to
get the school amplicon link which is
about 1,500 faces to rather than just
looking at one region and I think this
is particularly important as we start
thinking about linking across days and
I'll show an example of that so as part
of one of those the studies that we just
published in Nature Medicine this past
June I did a meta-analysis of several
studies that have looked at the vaginal
microbiome and preterm birth and this
includes four and these are four that
had included a number of women of
African ancestry and you can see here
that there are a lot of different
technical choices across the settings
everyone used a different collection
swab there were different hypervariable
regions used and even for the cases
where there were different hypervariable
regions people had different primers
primer selection and then on top of that
there's different sequencing
technologies so in terms of
harmonization there's certainly some
opportunities for microbiome studies to
start thinking about how each of these
choices impact the decisions and when we
see differences across studies are there
technological differences that are
driving these or their biological
differences or differences in the
experimental design I think there's a
lot of room to be done in this area
especially as we think about clinically
important
and how do we set up proper validation
studies one of the rules for I think the
long read sequencing is that there are
some cases where there are organisms
that have never been cultivated where we
don't yet have a full-length read that
apples the v1 to v3 region which a3
hypervariable regions is part of the 16s
gene with one of the v4 for example and
so it's impossible to actually link the
data between these studies and that's
something that I think there's quite a
bit of opportunity there for trying to
harmonize across studies using these
sorts of data so I'm going to switch
gears a bit and moved from some of the
ideas of just who is in a community and
this is a lot of the work when there
there are a large number of sample
studies that are using 16s surveys to do
that into what are they doing and how
are they interacting with the hosts over
time and I would say that the next piece
there would be to go through and take
the same sort of sample type and in that
case DNA from a mixed community and
apply a different technology so in this
case rather than just targeting one gene
to use as a marker essentially all of
the everything is sequenced and so again
if that's a vaginal swab sample if you
have human DNA viral DNA factory of our
bacterial DNA erbil DNA yeast DNA all of
that could be present and then there are
lots of different questions that could
be asked of that data so metagenomics is
the study of the collective genomes of a
microbial community without the need for
isolating or culturing cultivating that
in the lab so if we take this and we
apply short lead sequencing I like to
think about this as we went to the toy
store store and went to the puzzle aisle
and took lots of different numbers of
5000 piece puzzles dump them out onto
the ground and then threw the Box lids
away so you don't actually know what
you're looking for and so the approaches
that we have in this area I think
there's still a lot of room for
development one approach would be to try
to assemble that and that would just be
starting to put the pieces of the puzzle
together to see how far you can come
there might be cases where you can't go
any further but you can go through and
start to be
the other approach would say well maybe
you don't have the exact box lid but
maybe you have a relatively good
reference sequence and you can start
using that reference to go through and
map the reads to a reference approached
and the other the other piece would be
to go through and do something with the
reads directly and I think the approach
for what you do with this sort of data
really depends on what the question is
so are you asking just who's there are
you using this as a way to validate what
was found in the 16s survey data are you
looking to classify broad functional
categories of how many genes are
associated with carbohydrate utilization
and does that differ between you know
your your cases and your controls in
your particular study design are you
interested in string level comparison
and so that might be interesting some of
the questions that my group is asking in
terms of how two moms pass their
organisms to their infants certainly
asking is it the same organism that sort
of things is quite is quite interesting
or maybe you're just interested in a
particular class of genes so I'll give
one example here of antimicrobial
resistance genes and in that case you
don't care about the rest of it you're
just going in and trying to find
particular class of genes and pulling
those out so as you can see even despite
the fact that this is one technology the
types of approaches and the types of
questions that can be asked of these
data you know are really endless one of
the other directions that I think is
really interesting here is rather than
just work on informatics
techniques to make it possible to ask
new questions the other is to go through
and use new technologies to be able to
be the same and so some time back I was
actually putting together a reference
database for a vaginal 16s reference
database and I came across a new
organism that no one had reported before
but it was associated with a common
sexually transmitted infection called
tricking trichomoniasis and it was
associated with symptoms and so we
couldn't cultivate the organism and so
in this case
this was before before the long great
sequencing was available and so we used
the old port by port Roast platform to
go through in sequence sequencing
examples where there were high abundance
of this particular organism and a number
of technicians in my group went through
and actually closed all of the gaps
using standard approaches with P snoring
over those to go through and get a full
buccal circular genome and this was
quite exciting and one of the results
that came out of the preterm birth
publication that I just talked with you
about also included organisms that
hadn't been cultivated and this was
something that I was again we couldn't
cultivate some of these organisms and so
the question is well how do you move
forward how do you try to understand
something about an organism about which
we only know as 16s sequence and then in
this case it was early in pregnancy it
differentiated the women who went on to
deliver preterm from those who do not at
least in this proof of principle study
and so we're really interested in trying
to understand that and so in this case I
partnered with Nonna Scurlock at Pacific
Biosciences and his team and I had
samples that were not ideal they were
relatively low biomass they've been
cheered because in the case of the human
microbiome samples we use be beating
approaches because it's found that if
you go through and you use be beating
approaches you actually can go through
and break open cells you might not
otherwise break open and if you're
interested in just what's there that's
really important because we want to make
sure that we see everything and we don't
introduce bias in that sort of way but
if you're trying to get long reads this
approach also tends to cheer the DNA and
so these samples were not ideal for this
approach but we were able to go through
and get a new sacra bacterial sacra
bacterial organism from tm7 h1 which is
our provisional name for this new
organism that belongs to a newly named
phylum into conscience which was quite
easy to circularize and so that i think
is a really exciting new approach to
think about how metagenomics could be
paired where there is metagenomics were
looking for the development of new
reference databases you know and pair
with your cultivation
from selected samples to really
supplement a lot of the data that is
being generated using short reads so if
we go back to our our omics slide and we
think about what's kind of next along
the the route of omics you might think
it's a pretty easy to go from what's
there from the DNA perspective to what's
actually being transcribed so this is
what we call meta transcriptomics and so
again in this case it's a very similar
sort of technique so quickly again we
have a vaginal swab sample and in this
case rather than extracting DNA we
extract RNA and actually understand what
genes are been turned on and then we
could go through and do the simple
scenes similar sorts of bioinformatics
analyses using that sorts of that sort
of data
and so here's from from another group
one of the simple things that you can
ask is well did you get the same
composition if you use a 16s survey just
find out who's there or if you just go
through and you map the transcripts to
the organisms that you know do you get
the same survey and in some cases you
can see that at the transcript level
there's some organisms that have many
more transcripts which might mean that
they're more transcriptionally active
and then if you go down to the to the
gene level I think it's quite
interesting because there are a lot of
different things that you could do and
this is just kind of scratching the
surface here just to kind of get it to
give you a sense of the types of things
that can be done and how you frame the
question and how that matters and so one
of the things that we did recently with
the preterm birth data set was we
normalized using a global scaling
approach and that means we match the
transcripts to a database that we have
that we curated for vaginal organisms
and then from there we ask the question
are they up or down and creature more
term birth if we divide by all of the
genes that were from that there are
entire mapping file and that basically
gives us a way to ask the same question
is are there particular things at the
transcript level they're up in term or
up in preterm birth and for this it
really gave us a way to validate some of
the findings that we found
using the amplicon dia and then you can
think you can move beyond that from
beyond just at the transcript level do
you still see more of a particular
organism that are associated with one
particular condition if you pair this
sort of data with meta genomics data
they're analyzed in a very similar
fashion where you take the DNA samples
the meta Janome data and you map that to
a database and then you take a pair
example that was collected at the same
time and you take the meta transcriptome
data and you map that to the same
database you can ask well if you divide
the proportional abundance based on one
to the other you can actually start to
ask if there's a difference in the
relative transcriptional activity of a
particular taxon and one group compared
to the other and one of the things that
we found is talked about this organism a
couple of times is there there was a
difference in gardnerella vaginalis and
the transcriptional activity of the
women who went on to experience on
taneous preterm birth and another group
in and this this was actually a study of
metronidazole which is an antibiotic
that's often used to treat imbalance in
the vaginal microbiome and this group
used a tax on specific scaling approach
so rather than dividing by all of the
genes they just looked at the ones in
gardnerella and asked of the gardnerella
genes that were present are there
particular genes that were up or down in
a particular condition and that made it
possible for them to to find that there
were specific group of genes that were
that were upregulated compared to the
other and in this in this study and so I
think I think the thing that's really
important to think about here is that
there are a lot of different ways to do
the analysis from the same sort of data
set and there are a lot of opportunities
for those of you who might be interested
in method development to develop new
methods to increase the rigor in these
areas particularly as we move along from
16s into some of the other omics
technologies where we move to more
discovery based science there's really a
lot of opportunity and then method
development both from how do you
understand new features that are
important to look at and then how do we
handle the
you're lying statistics to improve rigor
in this area so in the interest of time
I'll I'll just go through the meta
proteomics and the tableau mix very
quickly I'll just give a couple of of
examples but there's some a lot of
really interesting studies that are
going on in these areas as well so this
was a really interesting study looking
at HIV - not prepared treatment in
African women and this was a group that
used here you'll see a profile here
we're looking at what textbook
taxonomically is present and this looks
very similar to some of the data that
you might see from 16s data but this was
used this was actually done using the
proteome what you think is quite
interesting and there are a lot of
really interesting ways that start
thinking about coupling the proteome -
the transcriptome to the meta-genome all
the way back to the surveys and I think
that's that's quite an interesting area
and here's one example of metabolomics
that was used to stratify different
subtypes of bacterial vaginosis which is
the most common and bacterial imbalance
that is clinically diagnosed and you can
see here that women who are negative or
positive for the bacterial vaginosis
status using hierarchical clustering
technique this group found that there
were multiple subtypes and I think
that's something in terms it's really
interesting to think about what are the
different groups of microbial
communities that might be responsible
for different metabolites and and how
does this all fit together as a system
and so I think that brings us to how do
we bring it all together
how do we go through and take all of
this really rich data that is now being
generated using these really cool new
multi-omics methods and how do we bring
it all together to make sense of all of
that I'll give a couple of examples of
some of the types of things that are
happening but I think this is an area
where it's just it's just a really
exciting area that's moving very rapidly
and so one common approach would be to
go through and look at one data type and
then lay others on so you can see here
this is actually a study where the
clustering is actually done based on I
mean the immune response and then the
other types including
measures of the microbiome are kind of
layered on top of that and that's one
sort of approach that's been classical
that's been used and has been useful in
terms of driving results forward David
Edwards who's part of the group at VCU
has been exploring using a method called
first canonical correlation analysis
since I know not all of you are
statisticians I won't go into too many
of the details here but there's a lot of
work that's going on about how do you
take different omics map measures that
have really different features so I
talked earlier about the fact that the
16s compositional data tends to be
sparse so there are lots of zeroes
meaning a lot of samples don't have some
of the things that are found and it's
proportional meaning it's constrained
and how do you integrate that with a
different data type that has a very
different different sorts of properties
and there's a lot of opportunities I
think from the statistics level in
addition to kind of the upstream
informatics level so that we can
understand how we can put this together
in terms of linking together the
different functional features that were
that we're talking about I think that's
quite exciting one of the things that
I'll mention is that the resources that
I talked about for the moms bi project
in addition to the other two projects
that were part of the HIV are all
publicly available you can go to the HMP
DAC I've listed the website here and you
can download that directly and a
colleague of mine has also put together
an R package for any of you who may be
our users to pull down the future data
if you'd rather not reanalyze all of the
upstream raw data from scratch but you
are interested in an easy-to-use our
package I suggest that that might be one
that you would want to take a look at as
well and I think I talked about this
earlier as really the challenges in
multi out filmic microbiome science but
I would say if these are also quite a
bit of opportunities and they really
differ so if we're thinking about what
are the challenges of what are the
opportunities when you're really pushing
the frontiers of what we can currently
do those are really opportunities where
we could think about new informatics
methods to identify features that have
never been identified before from some
of these data types and then as we start
to think about some of the technologies
that are becoming a bit more mature how
do we in it how do we increase rigor how
do we make sure that we are including
papa
positive and negative controls how do we
make sure that we're understanding the
sorts of bias how do we make sure that
we're able to harmonize across different
studies so that we can we can understand
if we look at the literature whether or
not there's there's good evidence that
we should move forward and invest in a
particular area and so I think that the
opportunity is in this area moving
forward really depends on where things
are in the maturity of the of the
technology and in terms of the the
analytical methods and so I'm going to
bring things back to - some of the
things that I care about I mentioned
that I'm certainly very interested in
the Mac the vaginal microbiome and I
think if we think about the fact that
there are signatures in the vaginal
microbiome that are linked to preterm
birth I'd like to think about in the how
in the future we may be able to use
these approaches to ultimately test to
assess risk and understand the
underlying mechanisms enough so that we
might use personalized treatments to
promote health in pregnancy and if you
have any questions my email address will
be available and you can email me and
contact me I'd be happy to answer any
questions so thanks so much and I really
appreciate all of your time